all right man so we're like 11 hour a
little over 11 hours from the episode
having dropped i'm sure by now you know
that netflix
crashed like right at midnight so many
people wanted to watch that the surface
went down for a bit i was awake we just
done uh a live q a on the instagram and
i was awake when it happened i saw it
come through my twitter i was like this
is amazing so yeah no i'm definitely
aware
did you see the memes of people posting
you as becna drinking coffee through a
straw like me just waiting for netflix
to pop back up i didn't see that last
night no that's amazing
so congratulations on uh what i would
say i think a lot of people are in
agreeance on this it's probably the the
best season of the show at least since
the first season if not in comparison
with that what was it like taking on
this this journey and learning the the
arc of your character from when we first
meet him i guess azdekna but then henry
and then once again as henry
beckner
i mean first of all i was genuinely
overwhelmed with with gratitude uh to to
to be a part of the show it really
was a very
strange and
just beautiful experience the whole
process of getting the role of meeting
matt and ross and then working with the
cast it was and the crew was just i just
you know i i've got nothing but just
like beautiful love to say and then sort
of on the personal work side of it it
was a pleasure you know it was a
challenge um but a challenge that i i
relished i saw a means to realize my
potential
to transcend my human form i always
loved characters that have
truth and grit and you know honesty to
them and i and i saw a lot of honesty in
in in henry and in one and in beckner
too and
for me as an actor and as an artist now
i'm always
looking to go as far as i can and this
was an opportunity to do that and and to
do that with fantastic writing because
the writing is what makes it right so
what we're saying i have to believe and
i believe everything so um it was just
amazing a total joy and so did you know
at the outset of this did the duffer
brothers come to you and say like look
becna's the big bad of the series like
we learn a lot of things in the in the
finale of this
season where like
it was it was vegna all along
he was behind almost like all of this
they so when i auditioned first of all i
had no idea i was only sent a couple of
sides from other projects and then
my second uh second callback was with
was with some dummy sites but very
limited limited amount of material and
then i went to go meet matt and ross and
it was at that point when i met them at
the end of our conversation that things
started to come out and they started to
tell me you know who this person was and
what i was going to be doing and and
i i just was buzzing i was just buzzing
it was just it's just an honor again i
just i honestly i i i feel like today
i'm just going to be just saying i'm so
grateful all the time but i really am
i'm just so grateful so given the way
that the finale ends
first of all it must be surreal to see
your your your body
get lit on fire and then shot with the
shotgun
he's out the window and then he
disappears he's essentially successful
in his plan right like we're definitely
going to be seeing you again in season
five right i couldn't possibly say
you'll have to hold your
breath so then what is it what was it
like shooting that or maybe not i mean
shooting i'm sure is very technical but
what was your reaction when you watched
it and saw your character
burned and then
and then blasted with uh with a shotgun
that's got to be strange it was amazing
i i would you know we were all together
on that last day and that was that was i
think
i think that was the very last day of
shooting as well
and i remember watching that shotgun
scene particularly and i was stood by
the monitors with matt and ross because
often i like to watch what you know what
my other team members are doing just
because i find it fascinating
and she looked so
cool
it was like i turned to the boys and i
was like
that's amazing she looks so dope that's
so sick and they were like right and i
was like yeah sick
[Music]
so that was really lovely to watch
somebody else you know just
look badass on camera um
and then you know to to kind of perform
it and to and to watch it all back
together um it was
you know it just felt right everything
felt right for the character um
in terms of like my sort of like jamie
as a person i i wasn't really thinking
about it very much i was like this
serves the story it looks amazing and
you know all those like shotgun blasts
that i'm doing
and of course like i'm not actually
being shot so you know we have to sell
those and make sure that they look great
and you know the way my mouth opens at
the end matt and ross matt and ross said
to me the other day they were like your
mouth opens so wide and we had to freeze
the shot
because we thought it was we thought
that like it had been like cg it's like
it drops really low and they're like
it's not it's just you and i was like
that's hilarious like you were possessed
i was like well you know it was like two
o'clock in the morning um but it just
everything just looks brilliant and
it's such a homage you know this show is
such an homage to all the things that we
love um and that i love um and so to
sort of be a part of that it's just it's
great it's just something it's brilliant
it's really cool so what goes through
your mind when people say
vector is the the scariest villain that
they've not only seen in the show but in
a lot of things in a long time and you
helped bring that that character to life
i giggle often i mean my reaction tends
to be what what i just gave you
it's funny i'm british so i'm often
terrible at even you know receiving
praise at all um but it takes a village
right and um and and to be
to be a a small part of bringing
something like this to life again is a
privilege and it's an honor
um so
yeah i i just
i'm just kind of like thank god it
worked
thank god it worked
[Music]